das heißt steve ist eigentlich eine ganz
schöne kannte hallo ich meine lieben
freunde und herzlich mir wurden wieder
viele coole fag zugesendet ich hab mir
fünf rausgesucht und die stelle ich euch
jetzt vor ich würde mich freuen wenn bis
zum ende dran bleibt und ich glaube ich
hab noch nie so schnell eine einführung
in eine fixe folge gemacht
der erste effekt ist eine ganz simple
sache die mir zugesagt wurde von
schaufel lp und zwar ist der schaufel lp
oder dem schaufel lp aufgefallen als er
meine letzte folge gesehen hat wo auf
einmalig da die lava hat allerdings auf
einmal an zu regnen und zwar macht lava
zu schwarze partikel löst regen bei lava
aus einfach weil das wasser auf das lawa
drauf plätschert und ankommender funken
humor und alles mögliche und es wird
natürlich nicht zu obsidian das wäre es
natürlich noch wenn man irgendwo im
lagerbecken hätte und nur bei einem
regenschauer wird es auf einmal zur
idealen werden aber es komme auf jeden
fall so schwartze partikelchen deswegen
gebe ich jetzt einfach mal toggle down
voll ein
den befehl damit es zu regnen anfing und
ihr seht schon da kommen ganz ganz viele
schwarz partikelchen raum zu ähnlich ist
das ja auch um etwa beim feuer also wenn
ich mir jetzt jemand feuerzeug nehme
sehr klug ich habe jetzt hier ein
feuerzeug und zündete sie einfach mal an
dann seht ihr auch da kommen so
schwartze partikelchen das ist jetzt
natürlich weil er gut wegen dem regen
geht das vorher direkt wieder aus aber
ihr seht doch schon so da kommen immer
so schwartze partikelchen auch wenn es
nicht regnen würde und hier bei der lava
ist es nur so als nur so wenn ich es
wirklich auch regnet deswegen jetzt mal
live hier doppelt und vor der tag in
folge weg und ihr seht dann jedoch die
schwarzen partikel hinweg finde ich ganz
cool ist mir bisher noch nicht
aufgefallen und ist eine ganz
interessante sache eine zweite effekt
wurde mir zugesendet von wally und zwar
schreibt der alukon kräftig habe ein
fake für dich das be oder entladen einer
ändert ruhe ist mit einem trichter nicht
möglich aber bei einer normalen truhe
schon schöne grüße erstmal danke schöne
grüße zurück weil ihr und ja das ist
richtig ich habe ja ich hab's mal
ausprobiert und zwar ganz normal mit
einer truhe ihr kennt das ich schmeiße
beispielsweise ein schwert rein oder mal
ein halbes deck pott all das
verschwindet da drin und kommt unten in
die truhe rein und wird derzeit nach und
nach durch den trichter dar eingeliefert
wenn ich hier natürlich so mache geht
das ganze auch ein bisschen schneller
der db schon alltag
und dann haben wir alles ionen in der
kiste drin das ist natürlich schön und
gut bei einer ändert roth geht das ganze
nicht ich hab auch noch mal minecraft
wiki nachgeguckt ob es dafür irgendeine
erklärung gibt eben eingriff wege steht
einfach nur das beladen von ändert ruhen
ist mit einem trichter nicht möglich da
denke ich mir nur so ok danke warum
zeigt euch das ganze ist auch nochmal
schmeiße ein buch drauf oder
beispielsweise mal ein bisschen ihr seht
schon das pop soul blogger quasi raus
wir gehen ihr hin und haben hier wieder
zwei pop soul also dass nicht alles rein
gekommen der ist es einfach hier drin
ich schmeiße mal eben den rest hier auch
noch mal eben rein sehtest und das
bleibt einfach im trichter das fällt
nicht in die natur rein ich verstehe
nicht warum weil wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise eine andere ändert ruhe
hätte und da wird dann beispielsweise
als pop soul reinfallen also ich nehme
es einfach die sachen aus dem trichter
raus und packte hier rein dann habe ich
natürlich hier genau die gleichen sachen
drin und farben damit zu bauen wäre viel
einfacher dann könnte dann nämlich
einfach ganz easy hier eine farm machen
und irgendwie mit redstone sagen okay
mit ganz vielen repeater nach und nach
mit wasser drüber gespült und dann
kommen die ganzen samen und blocken hier
ein oder ändert ruhe und damit der
ändert ruhe in meine andere ändert ruhe
die dann 20 kilometer weiter hinten bei
meinem zuhause steht und dann muss man
nicht mehr zu der farm hinlaufen die man
extra im flachland gemacht hat oder so
ich hoffe ihr wisst was ich euch ja
sagen möchte das ganze gab es dabei eben
minecraft mega prix konnte man diese
preis machen wo items durch geflutscht
sind da war das echt perfekt um irgend
welche farben zu machen ich könnte mir
nicht vorstellen mit diesem trichter
dass das irgendwann mal noch
implementiert wird dass es irgendwie
hier ein plopp ich weiß nicht woran es
liegt
eventuell ist jeder genaueres und dann
schreibt einfach und in die kommentare
und das war platz zwei dritter wurde mir
nämlich zugesendet von einer person die
anonym bleiben möchte da war ich dann
natürlich keinen namen nennen und zwar
schreibt diese anonyme person man kann
mit einem schwert an item frame
zerstören ich habe es in der version 1.8
wander getestet und bevor jetzt die
meisten kommen ja freunde ich falls man
kann mit einem schwert in minecraft ihn
nicht zerstören wenn ich hier drauf
schlage dann ist es natürlich im
creative mode zumindest im normalen
modus geht es natürlich schon aber im
creative mode haben die sechser so
gemacht dass man lieber nichts zerstören
kann damit man sich auf das töten von
mobs konzentriert weil es im creative
mit pc-games oft so war man hat dann
geschlagen mob drauf und ich hätte hier
schon wieder den block und dem druck und
dem blog abgebaut weil ich nicht richtig
getroffen hat
und das haben ja einfach gesagt ok mit
dem schwert kann man nix abbauen wenn
ich allerdings etwas anders in die hand
nehmen oder hier von fleisch dann geht
das wenn man kann halt nur mit dem
schwert nicht zerstören allerdings gibt
es ein paar items die man mit dem schwer
zerstören kann und zwar sind das
entities das habe ich jetzt gelernt
freunde ich weiß etwas ende dies sind
und zwar haben wir beispielsweise nicht
nur er hat ja gesagt ein bilderrahmen
ein bilderrahmen entity oder eine
rüstung ständer oder auch eine lore ist
ein entity also wenn ich hier mit dem
streitwert auf schlag geht es weg hier
dass die wiederum nicht dass es keine
entity das gebäck und das geht auch weg
und rein theoretisch gibt es noch in
welcher entities glaube sogar ein boot
ist auch ein entity also müsste einer
sein wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe
und ein boot ist auch ein entity also
kann ich auch kaputt machen also mit
einem schwert kann man nicht nur mops
töten und im creative hat nicht nur mops
töten und sonst gar nichts damit machen
sondern auch entities allgemein und mops
sind ja auch entities von daher danke
für den effekt anonyme personen und
werde demnächst in eurer wohnung in
minecraft plötzlich sei das würde den
mai kräfte ja ich würde was bei amazon
bestellen
ich wohne minecraft da in dem in dem
terrain mit dem mit den hohen bäumen ein
baumhaus wieder jedenfalls wenn ihr
daran im creative bodrum hampelt und
irgendwas kaputt machen wollt oder so
dann passt auf jeden fall auf dass da
keine bilderrahmen oder loren oder
rüstungen ständen oder jemals rumsteht
weil sonst könnte das mit dem schwert
ganz ganz schnell auch kaputt weil es ja
entities sind und deswegen kann ich ja
nix abbauen aber das schwert kann ich
tue das weil ich das schwerlich
vollidiot vierte wurde mir zugesendet
von diego lpl kate julio ich hoffe ich
habe ein richtig ausgesprochen
hallo contra wenn man auf einen trichter
einen zauber tisch platziert in einen
gegenstand auf den zauberte schropp geht
das item in den trichter aber wenn man
einen blog zum beispiel ein gold blog
auf den trichter platziert geht dies
nicht immer mal wieder times at 0 war
das da hinten schon ganz schnell wieder
dunkel wird das zeigt mir dass ich schon
sehr sehr lange defekts vollkommen offen
hat jedenfalls ziemlich erzählt andré
stand setzen und packte beispielsweise
ein zauberte strafe nämlich hier
eintrifft dann packt dabei
beispielsweise einen ton blog drauf und
dann im neuen traktor beispielsweise
eine rosa gefärbten ton drauf und wenn
ich jetzt hier irgendwas drauf schmeiße
geht es natürlich nicht durch hier
geht's natürlich auch nicht durch und
hier geht's allerdings durch das liegt
allerdings nicht an der besonderheit ist
sauber blogs mehr oder weniger die
beiden nämlich mal wieder weg also das
kann ich wieder abbauen ihr wisst ja
okay wenn auf den trichter ein
kompletter block drauf ist dann fällt er
nichts durch allerdings ist hier ist
durchgefallen das liegt allerdings nicht
an dem zauber tisch block sondern das
geht auch mit allen möglichen stufen
also einfach blocken die nicht ganz
komplett sind und zwar kann ich hier
auch einfach sachen durch schmeißen das
heißt wenn ihr rein theoretisch man kann
ja sein haus auch so bauen indem man das
so ein bisschen mit so hart steps macht
als auch seiner halben höhe
dann könnt ihr einfach müsste nicht
irgendwo so einen dummen tritt darum
stehen haben sondern ihr könnt einfach
theoretisch stellt euch einfach vor das
ist mein haus ich laufe hier hin kann
ihr hochlaufen blabla kann ich einfach
items reinstellen
ich bin nicht getroffen ich kann hier
einfach nicht ich kann mir da könnt ihr
euch freund einfach sagen hey kommen
will irgendwie wieder so eine kiste
packen kommen schmeißen wir die mal hier
bout hat geklappt ja schon reizen weg
dann schmeiß ich mal irgendwie hier noch
in altem hin und hier noch was und
jedoch was und es verschwindet einfach
hier drunter dem trichter zauberei blatt
und das ist eigentlich ganz cool um das
ganze so ein bisschen zu verstecken mehr
oder weniger man kann also durch habt
blöcke hat man items in den trichter
reinschmeißen und das ist nummer vier
danken licht juli uk glp für den fünften
fact grab ich mich einfach mal so ein
bisschen rein das ist aber eigentlich
auch relativ egal ob eine schein cloud
meint richter und dahinter ist eine
tolle rose
jedenfalls wurde mit defekt zugesendet
von
äpfel oder hefte oder happy ich weiß es
nicht wieder ein kleines l geschrieben
ein großes aber da jedenfalls schreibt
der alu kongress dann sollte ich jetzt
etwas beim zocken aufgefallen das
perfekt für den effekt wäre und zwar
steve ist fast zwei blöcke groß aber er
ist breiter als eine blase wenn man sich
das ganz normal hier anschaut sieht man
schon wenn man mal ganz genau auf meinen
arm achtet okay das ist jetzt bild mit
optimalen ok besitzt auch blöd ein
bisschen aber ich denke man sieht dass
ich hier sieht man es ganz gut ich bin
breiter die arme kommen so ein bisschen
gehen in die wand rein
das heißt ich bin mit armen angelehnt
ein meter breit und wenn ich mal so
schaue ich stoße mir oben an der decke
so mehr oder weniger den kopf also ich
bin genau zwei meter hoch weil laut
minecraft ist ein block 1 meter und auch
in den tiefen ist es so 5000 meter am
stück fahren sind 1000 blöcke also ich
wills 1000 nv sind ok 10.000 jedenfalls
kann man dadurch festhalten dass steve
zwei blöcke groß also zwei meter gross
und einen meter breit ist das heißt
steve ist eigentlich eine ganz schöne
kannte es ist mal wieder so ein
typischer damals in den effekt folgen
hätte ich den als fun fact abgestempelt
mehr oder weniger wenn ihr mehr solcher
sachen habt die irgendwie sowas so ein
bisschen außerhalb von minecraft
aufzeigen oder sowas wie minecraft als
schulfach fand ich auch extrem cool wo
mir das zu gesendet wurde als fake das
wusste ich zwar selber schon dass es an
manchen schulen unterrichtet wird
allerdings hätte ich nie gedacht dass
mir so was wirklich alsfeld zugesendet
werden je mehr solcher coolen sachen
habt könnt ihr mir das einfach per mail
an contractor gmail.com schreiben ich
hoffe euch hat die folge gefallen wenn
es euch gefallen hat zeigt nur noch mit
einer bewertung
wir sehen uns am nächsten